الى ملف يحرر روسيا على اوكرانيا حيث
اعلنت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه تجدد القصف
الروسي على منطقه في نيكولا جنوب البلاد
الروسي نفذ في الساعات الماضيه غاره جويه
واربع ضربات صاروخيه بالاضافه الى نحو 60
هجوما بمنظمات صاروخيه مختلفه
القوه الروسيه عشرات القتلى ونحو 160
اصابه خلال قسم نفذته ضد النواقعهم في ذا
بورودجيا جنوبيه البلاد
الروسيه استهدف تجمعات للقوات والاليات
العسكريه الاوكرانيه في مدينتي خيرسون
وانتونوفكا وبلدات مجاوره اخرى في الضفه
اليمنى
للجيش الاوكراني في مدينتي بخموط
والسوليدار اضافه الى بلده في مقاطعه طي
دنيا
وذكرت قياده الاركان الاوكرانيه انه تم
رصد سبع محاولات تقدم من روسيا في مقاطعه
ايدونيسكا واضافت ان الجيش الروسيه قرر
النقل وحدات من القوات المساحبه من خرصون
لتمركزه
تقدم للجيش الاوكرانيه في محوري
بمقاطعه لوجان شرقيه اوكرانيا
لروسيا انها كبدت القوات الاوكرانيه خسائر
كبيره ودفعتها لتراجع خلف سكه الحديد
لطريق الرابط بين مدينتي سباته
اعلنت نائبه رئيس الوزراء الاوكراني ارينا
بيتشوك بدا الاخلاء الطوعيه من الاراضي
التي استعيدت اخيرا من القوات الروسيه في
جنوب اوكرانيا
ستتحمل جميع التكاليف والمسؤوليات
المرتبطه بهذه العمليه
في الاخلاق وتحديدا الفئات الضعيفه التي
لا تستطيع اعاده نفسها وفقا تعبيرها